and that's it we finish creating our
content provider since this has been an
involved section let's talk about what
we created we started off by defining
the you are is that our content provider
will support we then updated our
contract to reflect these URIs from
there we built a uri matter that matches
these URIs two constants we use in
switch statements in all of the other
required content provider functions then
we implemented the get type function to
return the type of cursor return for
each URI we then implemented the content
provider query functions followed by the
right operations insert update and
delete finally we talked about the
optional bulk insert function to make
updates to our database in a single
transaction this performs much faster
and causes less wear and tear on the
flash chip compared to updating the
database in multiple transaction there
are lots of libraries out there in the
android open source world to help you
build content providers if you want to
use them you'll be able to use them now
with the confidence that you know how
they work and what they are doing so all
queries and updates to the database can
now be done through the content provider
interface but we're still not using in
our code let's fix that